These days, knowing how to code is like having
a superpower. You can make almost anything
you can dream up. But there still isn't a
simple place for new coders to get started
building cool, real stuff for the web.
Maybe you've heard about Raspberry Pi.
It's a little machine that helps teach kids
how computers work.
We got to thinking -- Raspberry Pi could be
great for teaching how the web works, too.
So we built something for Raspberry Pi called
Coder. Download it, put it on an SD card,
plug it in, and it turns your Raspberry Pi
into a simple place to write code and a mini
web server to run it on -- everything you
need to get started making real web things
using the real languages of the web. It's
also a simple, cheap way to get a server into
a safe learning environment like a classroom
or living room.
Coder is open source, because we know there
are tons of different ways of teaching...
AND learning. So everyone -- including you
-- can help make it better.
This is just the beginning. A little download
for everyone to get started.